This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're going to start today with a little experiment. I'll be the guinea pig. I'm going to open the stopwatch app on my phone. I'll hit start and count off 5 seconds while looking at the phone. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. Okay, let me do that again. 1, 2, 3, 5. Okay, let me do that again. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们今天从一个小实验开始。我来当这个小白鼠。我要打开手机上的秒表应用。我会点击开始，看着手机数出5秒钟。1，2，3，4，5。好，我再试一次。1，2，3，5。好，我再试一次。1，2，3，4，5。
Okay, now I'm going to hit start and count our 5 seconds without looking at the phone. 1, 2, 3, 4 4 5. It was 5.43 seconds. Let's do it again. 1 2 3 4 5. Much better. 5.2 seconds. Last time. One, two, three, four, five.
好了，现在我要点击开始，不看手机数出5秒钟。1，2，3，4，4，5。是5.43秒。我们再来一次。1，2，3，4，5。好多了。5.2秒。最后一次。一，二，三，四，五。
Five point five, nine seconds. The errors I made seem trivial. But it turns out they are not. Multiply the small mistakes I made in milliseconds over all the countless decisions I make every day, and you can end up with a serious problem. Multiply the errors I make as an individual by an entire society made up of other era-prone humans and you can get disaster. What makes these mistakes insidious is that they are rarely the result of conscious decision-making. Human judgment is imprecise.
5.59秒。我犯的错误看起来微不足道。但事实并非如此。把我以毫秒计的小错误乘以我每天做出的无数决定，你最终就会遇到严重的问题。把我作为个人犯下的错误，乘以一个由其他易错人类组成的整个社会，你就会酿成灾难。这些错误阴险的地方在于，它们很少是深思熟虑的结果。人类的判断是不精确的。
An imprecise judgment produces unwanted variability, what the Nobel Prize winning psychologist Daniel Kahneman calls noise. Wherever there is judgment, there is noise, and there is more of it than you think. This week on Hidden Brain, the gigantic effect of inadvertent mistakes in business, medicine, and the criminal justice system, and how we think have revolutionized many areas of the social sciences. He was my guest on Hidden Brain for our 100th episode. We talked about his early research and his first book, Thinking Fast and Slow. As we close in on our 200th episode, we wanted to bring him back to talk about a set of ideas
不精确的判断会产生不想要的变异性，诺贝尔奖得主心理学家丹尼尔·卡尼曼称之为“噪声”。哪里有判断，哪里就有噪声，而且噪声比你想象的要多。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们将探讨商业、医疗和刑事司法系统中无意失误的巨大影响，以及我们的思维方式如何彻底改变了社会科学的许多领域。他是我的嘉宾，曾做客《隐藏的大脑》的第100期节目。我们讨论了他早期的研究和他的第一本书《思考，快与慢》。随着我们接近第200期节目，我们想请他回来，讨论他一直在研究的一系列理念。
he's been working on for several years. They're described in his new book, Noise, a flaw in human judgment. Daniel Conneman, welcome to Hidden Brain. Glad to be here. I want to begin by exploring what you mean by the term noise. You spend sometimes starting an insurance company and one of the things an insurance company needs to do is to tell prospective clients how much their premiums are going to cost. So an
这些理念记录在他的新书《噪声：人类判断的缺陷》中。丹尼尔·卡尼曼，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里。我想从探讨你所说的“噪声”这个词的含义开始。你曾花时间参与创办一家保险公司，保险公司需要做的事情之一，就是告诉潜在客户他们的保费将花费多少。所以，一个
underwriter says, if you want us to cover you against this loss, here's this quote, from the insurance company's point of view, Danny, what is the risk of offering quotes that are too high and also quotes that are too low? Well, a quote that is too high, you are very likely to lose the business because there are competitors and they'll offer a better price. A quote that is too low, you're leaving money on the table and you may not be covering your losses if you do that to a great deal. So errors in both directions are costly. We define noises unwanted variability
核保人会说，如果你想让我们承保这笔损失，报价是这样的。从保险公司的角度来看，丹尼，报价过高和报价过低的风险是什么？嗯，报价过高，你很有可能会失去这笔生意，因为有竞争对手会提供更好的价格。报价过低，你就是在白白放弃利润，如果你这样做得很过分，你可能无法弥补损失。因此，两个方向的错误都是代价高昂的。我们将噪声定义为判断或决策中不希望有的
in judgments or decisions. That is, if the same client would get different quotes from different underwriters in the same company, this is bad for the company. And variability is a basic component of error. So I think of the insurance business as being driven by mathematics. That's my stereotype that there are hard-nosed statisticians who work at these companies. So I would not expect a quote from one underwriter to be widely different from the next. You asked executives at this insurance company how much variability they expected between underwriters.
变异性。也就是说，如果同一个客户从同一家公司的不同核保人那里得到不同的报价，这对公司来说是不好的。变异性是错误的基本组成部分。因此，我认为保险业是由数学驱动的。这是我的刻板印象，即这些公司里有铁面无私的统计学家。所以，我不会期望一个核保人的报价与下一个核保人的报价有很大差异。你问过这家保险公司的管理人员，他们期望核保人之间的变异性有多大。
What was their estimate of this kind of subjective variability? I mean, it turns out that there is a very general answer to that question and people have a very general idea about that number will be and it's around 10% now when we actually measured that in an insurance company, The answer was 55%. And that was a number that was an amount of variability, as we call it, an amount of noise, that no one expected. And that really is what set me off on this journey that led to this book. Now, the difference between 10% and 55% might seem trivial. Who cares? Well, the consequences of this variability were anything but trivial.
他们对这种主观变异性的估计是多少？我的意思是，事实证明，这个问题有一个非常普遍的答案，人们对这个数字有一个非常普遍的想法，大概是10%。而现在，当我们实际在一家保险公司测量时，答案是55%。这个变异量，正如我们所称的，噪声量，是没有任何人预料到的。这确实是我踏上这段促成这本书的旅程的起点。现在，10%和55%之间的差距似乎微不足道。谁在乎呢？嗯，这种变异性的后果绝非微不足道。
I mean, I asked people what actually would be the cost of setting up a premium that is too high or too low. And when they carried out that exercise, they thought that the overall cost of these mistakes within the billions of dollars. Now, what was in some sense saving that company was that probably other companies were noisy as well. But if you have a company that is noisy, well others are noise free, the noisy company is going to lose a lot of money very quickly. So, with the insurance company, it's not just that the insurance company is losing money.
我的意思是，我问过人们，制定过高或过低的保费实际成本会是多少。当他们进行这项练习时，他们认为这些错误的总成本高达数十亿美元。现在，在某种程度上拯救这家公司的是，其他公司可能也有噪声。但是，如果你的公司有噪声，而其他公司没有噪声，这家公司将很快损失大量的钱。所以，对于保险公司来说，不仅仅是保险公司在亏钱。
There is also a cost that's being paid by all the people who are trying to get insurance. It might be that if you happen to get a quote that's too high, you might end up being uninsured or you might be spending more on insurance that you need to be spending. There is sort of a general human cost to these errors, not just in terms of the bottom line for the insurance company. Well, of course, when you have a noisy underwriting system, then the customer is facing a lottery that the customer has not signed up for. And that is true everywhere.
所有试图购买保险的人也在付出代价。如果你碰巧得到了一个过高的报价，你最终可能会没有保险，或者你可能会把钱花在比实际需要更多的保险上。这些错误不仅对保险公司的底线有影响，对人类来说还有一种普遍的代价。嗯，当然，当你的核保系统存在噪声时，客户面对的就是一场他们并未参与的彩票。这种情况无处不在。
That is wherever people reach a judgment or a decision by using their mind, rather than computing. Wherever there is judgment, there is noise, and there is more of it than you think. I want to look at a few other places, because in some ways what's striking about your book is both a number of different domains where you see noise and the extent of noise in those different domains including in places where you really feel this should be a setting where noise does not play a role. out there who found that in asylum cases, this was a courtroom in Miami, one judge would grant asylum to 88% of the applicants and another granted asylum to only 5% of the applicants. So this is more than a lottery, this is like playing roulette. This is a scandal, clearly the system isn't operating well. In many situations it's just that when people look at the same
也就是说，无论人们是通过思考而不是计算来得出判断或决策，只要有判断，就会有噪声，而且噪声比你想象的要多。我想看看其他一些地方，因为在某种程度上，你的书引人注目之处不仅在于你看到噪声的各种不同领域，还在于噪声在这些不同领域中的程度，包括在那些你真的觉得噪声不应该起作用的场所。有研究人员发现，在庇护案件中，这是迈阿密的一个法庭，一个法官会批准88%的申请人的庇护，而另一个法官只批准5%的申请人的庇护。所以这不仅仅是一场彩票，这就像在玩轮盘赌。这是一个丑闻，显然这个系统运行得并不好。在许多情况下，只是当人们看到相同的
data, they see them differently. They see them more differently than they expect. They see them more differently than anyone would expect. That's the basic phenomenon of what we call system noise. That is, when you have a system that ought to be producing judgments or decisions that are predictable, they turn out not to be predictable and that's noise. You also describe in some ways there are different kinds of noise. So if you're an asylum judge and I'm an asylum judge and we have very different subjective readings that can produce very different answers. But it could also be that if you are reviewing a case in the morning and you are reviewing a case in the afternoon, it's possible that just within yourself your own judgments can be noisy. Can you talk about that
数据时，他们的看法不同。他们看问题的方式比预期的更加不同。他们看问题的方式比任何人预期的都要不同。这就是我们所称的系统噪声的基本现象。也就是说，当你拥有一个本应产生可预测的判断或决策的系统时，结果却变得不可预测，这就是噪声。你还从某种程度上描述了存在不同种类的噪声。所以如果你是一个庇护法官，而我是一个庇护法官，我们有非常不同的主观解读，这会产生非常不同的答案。但也有可能，如果你在早上审理一个案件，而在下午审理另一个案件，仅仅是在你自己的内心当中，你自己的判断也可能会产生噪声。你能谈谈这个
idea as well? I mean, it's not only possible, it actually is the case, that when people are asked the same question or evaluate the same thing on multiple occasions, they do not reach the same answers. For example, radiologists who have shown the same image on two separate occasions and are not reminded that it's the same image, really with the stressing frequency reach different diagnoses on the two occasions. That we know it's true even for fingerprint examiners whom we really would not expect to be noisy at all, but actually they vary when you show them the same fingerprints twice.
想法吗？我的意思是，这不仅有可能，而且事实确实如此，当人们在多个场合被问到相同的问题或评估相同的事情时，他们并不会得出相同的答案。例如，放射科医生在两个不同的场合看到同一张影像，并且没有被提醒这是同一张影像，在频繁的压力下，他们在两个场合确实会得出不同的诊断。我们知道，即使是对指纹鉴定人员来说这也是真的，我们本不期望他们会有任何噪声，但实际上，当你向他们展示两次相同的指纹时，他们的结论也会发生变化。
By the way, that's important. They do not vary in the sense that somebody would make a match on one occasion and would positively say, it is not a match on the other. But fingerprint examiners are allowed to say, I'm not sure. And between, I'm not sure, and I am sure that it's a matter, it's not a match. There is variability. One of the things that you point out is that you don't expect that the lottery of who is reviewing your file is going to make a huge difference or that extraneous factors would play a huge role. The researcher Uri Simonson found that college admissions officers pay more attention to the academic attributes of candidates on cloudy days
顺便说一句，这很重要。他们的变化并不是指某人在某种情况下会做出匹配，而在另一种情况下会肯定地说这不是匹配。但是指纹鉴定人员可以表达“我不确定”。而在“我不确定”和“我确定这是一个匹配/这不是匹配”之间，存在着变异性。你指出的事情之一是，你不会指望审查你档案的人是谁这场彩票会产生巨大的差异，也不会指望无关因素会扮演重要的角色。研究人员尤里·西蒙森发现，大学招生官在阴天时
and to non-academic attributes when the weather is sunny. He titled this paper, clouds make nerds look good. Talk about this idea that extraneous factors, whether someone's hungry, what the weather is like, that can affect people's judgment, too. Indeed, it's been established in the justice system. If you're a defendant, you have to hope for good weather, because on very hot days, judges assign most severe sentences. And that is true, though judges are here conditioned, but it's the outside temperature. Nevertheless, seems to have an effect.
会更多地关注候选人的学术属性，而在天气晴朗时则会关注非学术属性。他将这篇论文命名为“云朵让书呆子看起来很好”。谈谈这个想法，即无关因素，无论是某人是否饥饿，还是天气如何，也会影响人们的判断。确实，这在司法系统中已经得到了证实。如果你是一名被告，你必须祈祷天气好，因为在非常炎热的日子里，法官会判处最严厉的刑罚。这是真的，尽管法官们受到约束，但这是外部温度。尽管如此，似乎还是有影响。
It's been established in at least one study that for judges who are keen on football, the result of their team on Sunday or Saturday, depending on whether it's professional or college, will affect the judgment they make on the Monday. And they will be more severe if their team lost. No! He missed the extra point wide-right!
至少有一项研究证实，对于热衷于橄榄球的法官来说，他们的球队在周日或周六（取决于它是职业联赛还是大学联赛）的比赛结果会影响他们在周一做出的判决。如果他们的球队输了，他们会更严厉。不！他把那个额外的射门踢偏到右边去了！
That's a terrifying idea, isn't it, Danny, that you're sort of hoping that your judge's football team wins the Sunday before your case has heard. Oh, yes, absolutely. And you're also hoping to find a judge who is in a good mood, to find a judge who is rested, has had a good night, who is in a good mood, to find a drug who is rested, has had a good night, who is not too tired. And your chances of being prescribed antibiotics or painkillers differ
这是一个可怕的想法，不是吗，丹尼，你有点希望你的法官支持的橄榄球队在你的案件开庭审理前的那个周日赢球。哦，是的，绝对是的。而且你还希望能找到一个心情好的法官，找到一个休息好、睡了个好觉、心情愉快的法官，找到一个休息好、睡了个好觉、不太疲倦的法官。而你被开具抗生素或止痛药处方的几率也会有所不同
in the course of the day. So doctors tend to prescribe more antibiotics toward the end of the day when they are tired, than earlier in the day when they are fresh, and they are more likely to prescribe pain killers later in the day, simply because it's an effort to resist the patient who wants pain killers, and when you're very tired and depleted, that effort becomes more difficult. So completely extraneous factors have a distressing, laudrific. Noise in medicine often shows up under a different name. The most strange factors have a distressing leadodry effect. Noise in medicine often shows up under a different name.
在一天当中。因此，医生倾向于在一天结束时他们疲惫的时候开出更多的抗生素，而不是在他们精力充沛的一天开始时，而且他们更有可能在一天晚些时候开出止痛药，这仅仅是因为这是在抵制想要止痛药的患者，而当你非常疲倦和精疲力竭时，这种努力就变得更加困难。因此，完全无关的因素具有令人苦恼的、引发奇迹的效果。医学中的噪声通常以不同的名字出现。最奇怪的因素具有令人苦恼的误导效应。医学中的噪声通常以不同的名字出现。
Medical mistakes. Stunning medical news tonight about how many Americans have something go wrong when they go to the hospital. The astronomical number, one in three patients, will face a mistake during a hospital stay. And these are costly errors. One study estimate medical mistakes cost the US more than 17 billion dollars a year. The doctors had discovered that Sarah didn't have cancer in the first place. She'd been misdiagnosed and all the pain and treatment that she went through was for absolutely nothing.
医疗失误。今晚关于多少美国人在去医院时出现问题的惊人医学新闻。这个天文数字是，三分之一的患者在住院期间会面临失误。这些都是代价高昂的错误。一项研究估计，医疗失误每年给美国造成超过170亿美元的损失。医生们发现萨拉根本没有得癌症。她被误诊了，她经历的所有痛苦和治疗完全是白受罪。
So, Daddy, can you talk about these two different dimensions of noise in the medical sphere, the ways in which it might cause us to get diagnosed with conditions we might not have, but also for doctors to misconditions and problems that we actually do have? The contribution of noise is that which physician looks at the data makes a difference. And there is a lot of that, that is we know that physicians disagree on diagnosis and they also disagree on treatment. And that is a little shocking, that there is that element of lottery. So errors could happen for many reasons, including luck,
所以，丹尼，你能谈谈医学领域中噪声的这两个不同维度吗？一方面它可能会导致我们被诊断出我们可能并未患有的疾病，另一方面也可能导致医生对我们实际确实存在的病症和问题发生误诊？噪声的贡献在于，哪个医生看数据会有所不同。这种情况很多，也就是说，我们知道医生在诊断上存在分歧，在治疗上也存在分歧。这有点令人震惊，竟然存在这种运气的成分。因此，错误可能由于多种原因发生，包括运气，
which is not an area in judgment, but where information was missing. But in some cases, the errors cannot be described in any other way than noise that is different doctors looking at the same case, reaching different conclusions. It might seem obvious from these examples that noise is a big problem and that combating noise makes a lot of sense. Who could argue against reducing arbitrary decisions and inconsistent rules? It turns out a lot of people have a problem with doing just that, and one of those people might be you.
这不属于判断领域，而是信息缺失的地方。但在某些情况下，这些错误只能被描述为噪声，即不同的医生看同一个病例，得出不同的结论。从这些例子中似乎显而易见的是，噪声是一个巨大的问题，打击噪声很有意义。谁会反对减少任意决策和不一致的规则呢？事实证明，很多人对这样做有意见，而这些人中可能就包括你。
problem with doing just that and one of those people might be you. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We've seen how noise pervades many aspects of our personal and social lives. It can lead to wildly different estimates on our insurance premiums. It affects judgments, doctors make about our health. It can determine whether we get a job or a promotion. In their new book, Noise, a flaw in human judgment, Daniel Kahneman and his co-authors, Olivier Sibouny and Cass Sunstein, show that noise also shapes what happens in the criminal justice system. It affects decisions
对这样做有意见，而这些人中可能就包括你。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们已经看到了噪声是如何渗透到我们个人和社会生活的许多方面的。它会导致我们保险保费的估计大相径庭。它会影响医生对我们健康的判断。它能决定我们是获得工作还是得到晋升。丹尼尔·卡尼曼和他的合著者奥利维尔·西博尼以及卡斯·桑斯坦在他们的新书《噪声：人类判断的缺陷》中表明，噪声也塑造了刑事司法系统中发生的事情。它影响着
that send people to prison or sentence them to execution. Danny Judge Marvin Frankel worked as a United States District Judge and he made a name for himself by pointing out inconsistencies in the criminal justice system. He once wrote a case about two men convicted for caching counterfeit checks, both amounts were for less than $60. One man got a sentence of 30 days in prison. The other got 15 years. What did Judge Frankel make us such disparities? I mean, he thought it's unjust.
将人们送进监狱或判处死刑的决定。丹尼，马文·弗兰克尔法官曾担任美国地区法官，他通过指出刑事司法系统中的不一致性而名声大噪。他曾写过一个案件，涉及两名因兑换伪造支票而被定罪的男子，两人的金额都不到60美元。一个人被判处30天监禁。另一个人被判了15年。弗兰克尔法官对这种巨大的差异作何感想？我的意思是，他认为这是不公正的。
He thought it's extraordinarily unfair, I mean, which it seems to be on the face of it. So he really felt that the justice system should be reformed to avoid this role of completely unpredictable, unreasonable factors that determine the fate of defendants. You know, Danny, I feel like in the last year, I've seen dozens of stories that talk about disparities of all kinds, including disparities in the criminal justice system. And invariably, when I read these stories about disparities, they talk about the idea that it's about bias,
他认为这极其不公平，我的意思是，表面上看确实如此。所以他真的觉得应该改革司法系统，以避免这种完全不可预测的、不合理的因素来决定被告命运的角色。你知道，丹尼，我觉得在过去的一年里，我看到了几十篇关于各种差异的报道，包括刑事司法系统中的差异。而且无一例外，当我阅读这些关于差异的报道时，他们都会谈到这样一个观点，即这是关于偏见的，
that it's about racial bias or gender bias or some other kind of bias. So when Judge Frankl comes along and says, you know, defendants are being given vastly different sentences. The very first thing that pops in my head is maybe these defendants were of different races and what we're really seeing is racial bias at play rather than noise. How can we tell the difference between racial bias and noise? It's actually easy to do because when you want to measure noise,
这是关于种族偏见、性别偏见或其他某种偏见。因此，当弗兰克尔法官站出来说，你知道，被告被判处的刑期大相径庭。我脑子里首先浮现的想法可能是，这些被告属于不同的种族，我们真正看到的是种族偏见在起作用，而不是噪声。我们如何区分种族偏见和噪声呢？这其实很容易做到，因为当你想测量噪声时，
you can conduct a kind of study that we call the noise audit. And so you take professionals, for example, judges, and you show them a fictitious case, and you ask them to make judgments as they would normally. Now, you know that it's the same case, they've all been given the same information. They should give you the same judgment. The differences among them cannot be attributed to bias. And indeed, when Judge Frankl calls to happen,
你可以进行一种我们称之为“噪声审计”的研究。所以你找来专业人士，例如法官，向他们展示一个虚构的案例，并要求他们像往常一样做出判断。现在，你知道这是同一个案件，他们都得到了相同的信息。他们应该给你相同的判断。他们之间的差异不能归咎于偏见。事实上，当弗兰克尔法官碰巧这样做时，
he calls many noise audits to be performed. He actually conducted some himself. And in the most famous one, 208 federal judges evaluated 16 cases and assigned sentences to 16 cases. And this gives you an idea of the lottery that a defendant would face, in that where the average sentence is seven years in jail, the probable difference between two judgments is over three years. So that seems to be unacceptable.
他呼吁进行许多噪声审计。他实际上自己也进行了一些审计。在最著名的一次审计中，208名联邦法官评估了16个案件，并为16个案件做出了量刑。这让你对被告将面临的彩票有了一个概念，其中平均刑期是七年监禁，两次判决之间的可能差异超过三年。所以这似乎是不可接受的。
So, based on the work of Judge Franklin others, Congress eventually passed a law that basically limited the amount of discretion that judges had. Talk about the effects that this law had on reducing noise, were their studies conducted to actually figure out if these were reducing noise? Yes, studies were conducted and actually you can look at many cases and look at the variability of judgments, many cases and you find that the variability significantly diminished, which indicates that their noise was in fact reduced. However, something else happened. The judge was hated it. They hated this restriction on their ability to make free decisions, and they felt that justice was not being served.
因此，基于弗兰克尔法官和其他人的工作，国会最终通过了一项法律，基本上限制了法官的自由裁量权。谈谈这项法律在减少噪声方面产生的影响，是否进行了研究来真正弄清楚这些是否减少了噪声？是的，进行了研究，实际上你可以查看许多案件并观察判决的变异性，许多案件表明变异性显著减小，这表明噪声实际上确实减少了。然而，发生了另一件事。法官们对此恨之入骨。他们讨厌这种对自己做出自由决定能力的限制，他们觉得正义没有得到伸张。
So even as the data was showing that the noise was reducing and sentencing, in other words, sentencing was becoming more consistent. Many judges were upset that their discretion was being taken away. And Judge Jose Cabránis was one of those who spoke up. And I want to play you a clip of something he said in 1994. This was a discussion at Harvard University where they were talking about these guidelines that were aimed to reduce ethnic disparities
因此，尽管数据表明量刑中的噪声在减少，换句话说，量刑变得更加一致。许多法官对他们的自由裁量权被剥夺感到不满。何塞·卡布拉尼斯法官就是直言不讳的人之一。我想播放一段他在1994年发言的音频片段。这是在哈佛大学举行的一场讨论，他们讨论了旨在通过限制法官的自由裁量权来减少民族差异的这些准则。
and sentencing by limiting the amount of discretion that judges had. Here is Judge Cabránis. These arcane and mechanistic computations are intended to produce a form of scientific precision, but in practice they generate a dense fog of confusion that undermines the legitimacy of the judges' sentencing decisions. Dhani, I want to draw your attention to what Judge Cabrán is saying. When you limit the variability of sentencing, you're telling judges,
在量刑方面。这里是卡布拉尼斯法官。这些晦涩难懂和机械化的计算旨在产生某种形式的科学精确度，但在实践中，它们产生了密集的混乱之雾，破坏了法官量刑决定的合法性。达尼，我想把你的注意力吸引到卡布拉尼斯法官所说的话上。当你限制量刑的变异性时，你是在告诉法官，
for this offense, you have to do X, for that offense, you have to do Y, a lot of judges feel their hands are tied and they feel the art of law is being reduced to a mechanistic science. Well, you know, if it takes a mechanistic science to produce justice, then I think we should seriously consider some mechanistic science. And what seems to be happening is that from the perspective of the judge, they feel that they're evaluating every detail of the case and that they are producing a just judgment because they are convinced that what they are doing is a just
对于这个罪行，你必须做X，对于那个罪行，你必须做Y，很多法官觉得他们的手被绑住了，他们觉得法律的艺术正在被简化为一种机械化的科学。嗯，你知道，如果需要一门机械化的科学来伸张正义，那么我认为我们应该认真考虑一些机械化的科学。而似乎正在发生的是，从法官的角度来看，他们觉得他们正在评估案件的每一个细节，并且他们正在做出公正的判决，因为他们确信他们正在做的是一个公正的
judgment. And somehow it's very difficult to convince judges that another judge from their respect a great deal, presented with the same case, would actually pass a different sentence. That argument doesn't seem to have penetrated when Judge Cabrames made that assertion, that in fact there is a problem and there is a problem to be resolved.
判决。不知何故，要说服法官们非常尊敬的另一位法官，在面对同一个案件时，实际上会做出不同的判决，这是非常困难的。当卡布拉尼斯法官断言确实存在问题且有待解决的问题时，这种论点似乎并没有深入人心。
He was in effect as I hear him. He was denying the existence of a problem. Hmm. Psychologists talk about a phenomenon called naïve realism that in some ways explains why it is, I am bewildered that you would not see the world exactly the way that I see the world. Can you explain what naïve realism is and how it speaks to the question we just discussed about judges not just reaching different conclusions but being bewildered that anyone would reach a different conclusion than them.
在我听来，他实际上是在否认问题的存在。嗯。心理学家谈到了一种被称为“朴素现实主义”的现象，它在某种程度上解释了为什么我会对你居然没有用我看到世界的方式来确切地看世界感到迷惑不解。你能解释一下什么是朴素现实主义，以及它如何说明我们刚才讨论的关于法官不仅得出不同的结论，而且对任何人会得出与他们不同的结论感到迷惑不解的问题吗？
Well, you know, we feel that we see the world as it is. It's the only way we see it, and what we see is real, what we see is true. And it makes it very difficult to believe and to imagine that someone else looking at the same reality is going to see it differently. But in fact, we are struck by how different they are in the context of criminal justice, the variability in sentences, is shocking. But when you're looking at it from the perspective of a judge who looks at cases individually and feels that he or she is making correct judgments for every case individually, then it looks as if any attempt to restrict their freedom is going to cause injustice to be performed. But they are simply not accepting, I think, the statistics that
嗯，你知道，我们觉得我们看到的世界就是它本来的样子。这是我们看到它的唯一方式，我们看到的是真实的，我们看到的是真的。这使得我们很难相信和想象其他人看到同样的现实会有所不同。但事实上，我们在刑事司法背景下对他们的差异之大感到震惊，刑期的变异性是令人震惊的。但是，当你从一个法官的角度来看待它时，他或她会单独审视案件，并觉得他或她是在为每个案件单独做出正确的判断，那么这就好像任何限制他们自由的企图都会导致不公正的发生。但他们根本不接受，我认为，那些
tell them that another judge looking at the same case would actually pass a different sentence. So these debates about sentencing reform raged in the 1980s and 1990s, and eventually in the early 2000s, the Supreme Court struck down the guidelines that bound the way judges were operating, and sentencing reform essentially went away, giving discretion back to judges. Is what happened, what I fear happened? Did noise come back into the system? Oh yes, I mean there is evidence that noise came roaring back and there is also evidence that judges were a lot happier
告诉他们另一位法官审视同一个案件实际上会做出不同判决的统计数据。因此，关于量刑改革的这些辩论在20世纪80年代和90年代甚嚣尘上，最终在2000年代初，最高法院推翻了约束法官行事方式的准则，量刑改革基本上消失了，将自由裁量权交还给了法官。事情是这样的吗，是我所担心的那样吗？噪声又回到了系统中吗？哦，是的，我的意思是，有证据表明噪声卷土重来，也有证据表明，没有了这些准则，法官们比以前快乐多了。
without the guidelines than they had been earlier. One of the ironic things that you and others have found is that even though there is this distinction between noise and bias, when the noise came back after the Supreme Court ruling, black defendants were actually among those who were the most severely harmed by this. Is it possible in some ways they can be intersections between noise and bias? In other words, they can amplify one another? Certainly.
你和其他人发现的讽刺的事情之一是，尽管噪声和偏见之间存在这种区别，但在最高法院裁决后噪声卷土重来时，黑人被告实际上是受害最严重的人群之一。在某种程度上，噪声和偏见之间可能存在交集吗？换句话说，它们会相互放大吗？当然。
I mean, when you are constraining people and reducing noise, you're reducing the opportunities for bias to take place. So attempts to reduce noise and attempts to control noise are going to, in general, not invariably, but are very likely to control and reduce bias as well. If noise produces many of the adverse outcomes we see, if noise produces much of the unfairness we see, we see, if noise produces much of the unfairness we see, why is it that critiques of disparities invariably talk about bias? Turns out that's because of the way our minds work. As we discussed in a recent series of episodes, the brain is a storytelling machine, and the story of bias caders to our hunger for simple explanations. I mean, clearly, bias in general is a better story. That is, you see something happening.
我的意思是，当你约束人们并减少噪声时，你就减少了偏见发生的机会。因此，减少噪声和控制噪声的尝试通常（虽然不总是）极有可能控制和减少偏见。如果噪声产生了我们看到的许多不利结果，如果噪声产生了我们看到的许多不公平现象，我们看到，如果噪声产生了我们看到的许多不公平现象，为什么对差异的批判总是谈论偏见呢？事实证明，这是因为我们大脑的工作方式。正如我们在最近的一系列节目中所讨论的，大脑是一个讲故事的机器，偏见的故事迎合了我们对简单解释的渴望。我的意思是，显然，偏见通常是一个更好的故事。也就是说，你看到某事正在发生。
It had the character of an event. It had the character of something that is caused by a psychological force of some kind. Variability noise is uncaused. Noise doesn't lend itself to a causal story and really the mind is hungry for causes and that leads us very naturally to thinking to him the biases. That errors must be explainable. So if I get a misdiagnosis because a doctor doesn't like the color of my skin, that might not make me feel good, but at least I can make sense of what happened. Once I settle on an explanation of racism or sexism
它具有事件的特征。它具有某种由某种心理力量引起的事件的特征。变异性/噪声是无因的。噪声不适合讲因果故事，而且大脑确实渴望原因，这非常自然地引导我们思考偏见。即错误必须是可以解释的。因此，如果我因为医生不喜欢我的皮肤颜色而得到误诊，这可能不会让我感觉良好，但至少我可以理解发生了什么。一旦我接受了种族主义、性别歧视
or homophobia, I tell myself I have every right to get angry. When I discuss what happened with others, they'll get angry too. By contrast, a misdiagnosis produced by noise is, by definition, no one's fault. The error may have harmed me, but I can't lay the blame on someone's evil intentions. Noise is a very opposite of a good story. It's meaningless, and that can make me feel even worse. Here's another problem. When I see a judge pass a really harsh sentence or a very even worse. Here's another problem. When I see a judge pass a really harsh sentence or a very light sentence, I can come up with
或恐同症的解释，我告诉自己我有充分的理由生气。当我与其他人讨论发生的事情时，他们也会生气。相比之下，由噪声产生的误诊，按定义来说，是谁的错都不是。这个错误可能伤害了我，但我不能把责任归咎于某人的恶毒意图。噪声是好故事的对立面。它是毫无意义的，这会让我感觉更糟。这里还有另一个问题。当我看到一个法官判处非常严厉的刑期或更糟的刑期时。这里还有另一个问题。当我看到一个法官判处非常严厉的刑期或非常轻的刑期时，我可以想出
a story of bias to explain this individual case. You cannot do that with noise. You cannot spot noise by looking at any individual case. You have to measure it in the aggregate. It shows up only when you look at the statistics and many of us are uncomfortable turning to data as our guide to the truth. Reprefer stories and anecdotes and stories and anecdotes are better at illustrating the problem of bias. Stories and anecdotes are what the mind is prepared for. Statistical thinking is alien to us.
一个关于偏见的故事来解释这个个案。你不能用噪声做到这一点。你不能通过看任何个案来发现噪声。你必须在总体中衡量它。它只在你查看统计数据时才会出现，而我们许多人很不习惯将数据作为我们寻找真理的指南。我们更喜欢故事和轶事，而故事和轶事更善于说明偏见的问题。故事和轶事是大脑准备好接受的。统计思维对我们来说是陌生的。
And statistical thinking is the only way to detect noise because it's variability. It's sort of absurd to say about any single case that it is noisy. You say that if you have no idea of how it came about. But noise is a phenomenon that you observe statistically and that you can analyze only statistically. And that is not appealing. So there's an even deeper problem than the fact that noise is detectable only through statistics,
而统计思维是检测噪声的唯一方法，因为它是变异性。对于任何单个案例说它是有噪声的，这有点荒谬。如果你不知道它是如何产生的，你会这么说。但噪声是一种你可以从统计学上观察到并且只能通过统计学进行分析的现象。这是很不吸引人的。因此，存在一个比“噪声只能通过统计数据检测到，
whereas bias, you can tell a story about bias. For many people making decisions, the data is simply not even available. So at a statistical level, you can see an insurance company is demonstrating noise, but many of the decisions we are making are decisions we make as individuals. So if I want to propose marriage, and I feel like proposing marriage on a moonlit night in the spring time, I have no idea if my decision to propose marriage on that evening is being shaped by noise or not. I don't have a statistical set of how I would behave on the different circumstances. You know, the truth of the matter is that no one can tell you that this decision was noisy.
而偏见你可以围绕它讲一个故事”更深层次的问题。对于许多做出决策的人来说，数据甚至根本无法获得。所以在统计层面上，你可以看到一家保险公司表现出噪声，但我们做出的许多决定都是我们作为个人做出的决定。所以如果我想向人求婚，并且我觉得在春天的月夜求婚很好，我不知道我那天晚上求婚的决定是否受到噪声的影响。我没有关于我在不同情况下会如何表现的统计数据集。你知道，事实是，没有人能告诉你这个决定是有噪声的。
What you can tell is that when you look at the collection of decisions of people deciding to get married, that collection is noisy. There is no reason to believe that these steps which improve judgments in the statistical case do not apply when somebody decides to get married. If noise is present in the decisions where you can observe it, it's also present when you cannot observe it. Some years ago, I interviewed the researcher Berkeley-Datewurst. He talked about how people respond when a mistake has been made by a human
你能说的是，当你查看人们决定结婚的决策集合时，那个集合是有噪声的。没有理由相信这些在统计案例中改善判断的步骤在某人决定结婚时不适用。如果在你可以观察到它的决策中存在噪声，那么在你不可以观察到它的决策中也同样存在。几年前，我采访了研究员伯克利·代特沃斯特。他谈到了当人类犯错与算法犯错时人们如何反应。
versus an algorithm. I want to play you a short excerpt of something he told me. People fail to use the algorithm after they'd seen the algorithm perform and make mistakes, even though they typically saw the algorithm outperform the human. In our studies, the algorithms outperform people by 25 to 90%. So he's basically saying the algorithms are significantly better than the humans, but when a mistake is made, and algorithms, of course, can make mistakes, and humans can make mistakes, he's saying that you prefer the human to make the mistake. And I think intuitively that feels correct to me. If I'm going to get a misdiagnosis when I go to a doctor, I would feel better if it's the doctor who's made
我想播放一段他告诉我的一小段节选。人们在看到算法表现并犯错后，不再使用算法，尽管他们通常看到算法的表现优于人类。在我们的研究中，算法的表现比人类高出25%到90%。所以他基本上是说算法明显比人类更好，但是当犯错时，算法当然会犯错，人类也会犯错，他是说你更愿意让人类犯错。我认为直觉上这对我来说是对的。如果我去医院看病被误诊了，如果是医生犯了错误，我会感觉比一个没有感情、不会思考的算法犯错要好。我认为这绝对是真的。而且，你知道，当我们看到道路交通事故时，如果那是驾驶员的错误，我们会觉得没那么糟糕，而不是由自动驾驶汽车引起的事故。算法，它们会犯错。
the mistake than an unfeeling, unthinking algorithm. I think that's absolutely true. And, you know, when we're looking at a road accident, we somehow feel less bad about it, if it was a driver error, then if it was a self-driving car that caused the accident. Algorithms, they make errors. The error they make, by the way, are different from the errors that people would make,
顺便说一句，它们犯的错误与人们会犯的错误不同，
and they look stupid to people. Algorithms make errors that people would make, and they look stupid to people. Algorithms make areas that people think are ridiculous. Now we don't get to hear what algorithm think of the areas that people make. And we do know that algorithm just make far fewer of them in many cases, and you have to trade off the higher overall accuracy against the discomfort of abandoning human judgment and trusting an algorithm. Yeah.
而且在人们看来它们很愚蠢。算法犯的错误是人们会犯的，而且在人们看来它们很愚蠢。算法犯的错误是人们认为荒谬的。现在我们听不到算法对人们犯下的错误的看法。而且我们确实知道，在许多情况下，算法犯的错误要少得多，你必须权衡更高的整体准确性与放弃人类判断和信任算法的不适感。是的。
You know, this might actually be a subtext of much of your lifetimes work, Danny, but it seems to me that fighting noise requires a certain amount of humility, and it seems to me that humans are not humble. Well, they're not humble for fairly straightforward reason. We do not go through life imagining different ways of seeing what we see. We see one thing at a time, and it feels right to us. And you know, that is really the source of the problem of ignoring noise. This is why it is so difficult to imagine it. I want to talk just for a brief moment about places where noise can potentially be useful.
你知道，这实际上可能是你一生工作的潜台词，丹尼，但对我来说，打击噪声需要一定程度的谦逊，而人类似乎并不谦逊。嗯，他们不谦逊的原因很简单。我们没有经历过想象用不同的方式来看待我们所看到的东西的生活。我们一次看一件事，这对我们来说感觉是对的。而且，你知道，这确实是忽视噪声问题的根源。这就是为什么很难想象它的原因。我想花一点时间谈谈噪声可能有用处的地方。
So let's say, for example, you have a company that's trying to innovate and come up with new ideas, or you're in a creative enterprise where you're going to pitch different ideas for movies. In some ways you might want to actually maximize the variability of the ideas you get. So noise is not always bad, sometimes it can actually lead to good things. Yeah, we don't call it noise in those cases. So we reserve the term noise for undesirable variability. There are indeed many situations in life in which variability is a blessing, certainly in creative enterprises, also evolution. So anything that allows you to select the better one of multiple responses wherever there
所以比方说，你有一家公司正在努力创新并想出新点子，或者你身处一个创意企业，你将为电影提出不同的创意。在某种程度上，你可能实际上想要最大化你得到的创意的变异性。所以噪声并不总是坏事，有时它实际上可以带来美好的事物。是的，在这种情况下我们不称之为噪声。因此，我们将“噪声”这个词保留用于不良的变异性。生活中确实有许多情况变异性是一种福气，在创意企业中当然如此，进化中也是如此。因此，任何允许你从多种反应中选择更好的一种的机制，无论
is a selection mechanism, variability is a good thing. But variability in the absence of a selection mechanism is a sheer loss of accuracy. And those are the cases that we talk about. So if you had a way when you have multiple underwriters of finding out who is doing a better job than whom, and using that in order to improve their training, that would be a case where you could make positive use of variability, but in the absence of such a mechanism,
哪里有选择机制，变异性都是一件好事。但在没有选择机制的情况下，变异性纯粹是准确性的损失。这就是我们所讨论的案例。因此，如果你有一种方法，当你有多个核保人时，能够找出谁的工作做得更好，并利用这一点来改善他们的培训，这将是你可以积极利用变异性的案例，但在没有这种机制的情况下，
that variability just is a sheer loss. When we come back, how to fight noise? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When we come back, how to fight noise? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Noise is endemic. It's also very difficult to fight in part because judges and doctors and police officers don't like to think of themselves as capricious. We don't think of our judgments as being arbitrary, certainly not when it comes to really important decisions.
这种变异性纯粹是一种损失。稍后回来，如何打击噪声？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。稍后回来，如何打击噪声？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。噪声是普遍存在的。它也很难对抗，部分原因在于法官、医生和警察不愿意认为自己喜怒无常。我们不认为我们的判断是随心所欲的，在真正重要的决策上绝对不会。
Even when we are told about how noise is affecting our judgments and decisions, we hate to be shackled by rules. Danny in 1907, Charles Darwin's cousin, Francis Galton, asked 787 villagers at a county fair to estimate the weight of a prize ox. None of the villagers guessed the right answer, but then Galton did something with their answers that got him very close to the correct answer. What did he do, Danny? Well, he simply took the average, and the average, I think, was within two pounds of the correct weight. And that led to a lot of research that was summarized in a recent book by James Sura Wiecki on the wisdom of crowds, and the fact that when you take multiple judgments, independent judgments, and average them, you eliminate noise. This, by the way, is guaranteed to eliminate noise. So if you take multiple judgments, there is no guarantee that it will reduce bias
甚至当我们被告知噪声如何影响我们的判断和决策时，我们也很讨厌被规则束缚。丹尼，在1907年，查尔斯·达尔文的表弟弗朗西斯·高尔顿要求乡镇集市上的787名村民估计一头获奖公牛的体重。没有一个村民猜对答案，但随后高尔顿对他们的答案做了一些处理，使他非常接近正确答案。他做了什么，丹尼？嗯，他只是取了平均值，而平均值，我认为距离正确体重不到两磅。这引发了大量研究，詹姆斯·苏罗维基最近在《群体的智慧》一书中总结了这些研究，即当你采用多个独立的判断并求平均值时，你就消除了噪声。顺便说一句，这保证能消除噪声。因此，如果你采用多个判断，并不能保证它会减少偏见，
because this the judges agree on the bias, then the bias will remain when you take the average. Indeed, it will be even more salient. But what is absolutely guaranteed is that when you average independent judgments, you are eliminating noise. When you take four and a hundred judges, you are reducing noise by one half. When you take a hundred, you're reducing it by 90%. So there is some mathematics of noise that lends itself to analysis that doesn't apply to bias. So it's really remarkable. The correct weight of that ox was 1,198 pounds. And as you said, that was one or two pounds off the correct weight. And I want to point out that the reason averaging the responses produces a better answer
因为如果法官对偏见达成一致，那么当你取平均值时，偏见依然存在。事实上，它会变得更加突出。但绝对可以保证的是，当你对独立的判断求平均值时，你正在消除噪声。当你聘请4名和100名法官时，你将噪声减少了一半。当你聘请100名法官时，你将其减少了90%。因此，噪声有一些适用于分析的数学原理，而这些原理不适用于偏见。所以这真的很了不起。那头公牛的正确体重是1,198磅。正如你所说，这与正确体重相差一到两磅。我想指出的是，对反应求平均值能产生更好答案的原因
is that noise is random. You're taking advantage of the fact that various estimates will be randomly high or low and that's why when you average them out, you're going to get closer and closer to the correct answer. And what happens when you have different people making the same judgment of the same objects and then you are going to average them, then the errors they make cancel each other out. But when people make judgments about different cases, errors don't cancel them out. If you set too high a premium in one case and too low a premium in the other case, that doesn't make you right. That just makes things worse. So this idea that errors cancel out, you have to apply it quite precisely.
这种噪音是随机的。你正在利用这样一个事实：各种估计值会随机偏高或偏低，这就是为什么当你将它们平均时，你会越来越接近正确答案。当不同的人对相同的对象做出相同的判断，然后你要对它们进行平均时，他们所犯的错误会相互抵消。但是，当人们对不同的案件做出判断时，错误并不会相互抵消。如果你在一个案件中设定过高的保费，而在另一个案件中设定过低的保费，这并不能证明你是对的。这只会让事情变得更糟。所以，错误会相互抵消这个观点，你必须非常精准地应用它。
They cancel out when you average judgments are the same thing. And also the judgments have to come from people who in some ways who are independent of one another. If I am seeing the judgment you make and then I make my judgment afterwards, my judgment really is just a reflection of your judgment, not an independent one. That's right. And, you know, what happens, basically, is when you have witnesses who talk to each other, the value of their testimony is sharply reduced. Because in effect, in the extreme, if you have one witness who is very assertive, all the other witnesses fit their story to his, then you have one witness, regardless of how many testify.
当你们对同一事物的判断进行平均时，它们会相互抵消。而且，这些判断必须来自在某种程度上彼此独立的人。如果我看到你做出的判断，然后我接着做出我的判断，我的判断其实只是你判断的反映，而不是一个独立的判断。确实如此。而且，你知道，基本上发生的情况是，当目击者互相交谈时，他们证词的价值会急剧下降。因为实际上，在极端情况下，如果你有一个非常自信的目击者，所有其他目击者都把他们的说法迎合他，那么不管有多少人作证，其实你都只有一个目击者。
One of the most remarkable aspects of the wisdom of the crowd that you describe in the book has to do with how you can elicit the wisdom of the crowd just from yourself. You cite research by Edward Wool and Harold Pashler that asked people to make judgments about the same thing separated by a certain amount of time. What do they find when you average out these different estimates? Well, for example, you know, if you ask people whether the population of London and you ask it once and then you wait a couple of weeks, say, and you ask it again, the striking thing is that most people will not give you the same number on the two occasions. And the second striking thing is that the average of the two responses is more likely to
你在书中描述的群体的智慧最显著的方面之一，与你如何仅仅从你自己身上就能引发群体的智慧有关。你引用了爱德华·乌尔（Edward Wool）和哈罗德·帕施勒（Harold Pashler）的研究，该研究要求人们对同一事物间隔一定时间做出判断。当你把这些不同的估计值平均后，他们发现了什么？嗯，例如，你知道，如果你问人们伦敦的人口是多少，你问了一次，然后等了几个星期，比方说，你再问一次，最引人注目的是，大多数人在两次机会中不会给出相同的数字。第二个引人注目的是，两次回答的平均值更有可能
be accurate than either of the responses. The first response is better than the second, but the average is better than both. In one of the studies they conducted, they actually asked people to make estimates that were different than their initial estimates, and then they averaged out the estimates, and they found that noise was reduced even further. Why would this be the case, Danny? Well, here what you're trying to do, and you can do it within an individual, is you're leaning against yourself.
比任何一个回答都更准确。第一次回答比第二次好，但平均值比两次都好。在他们进行的一项研究中，他们实际上要求人们做出不同于他们最初估计的估计，然后他们将这些估计进行平均，他们发现噪音被进一步减少了。丹尼，为什么会这样？嗯，在这里你试图做的是，你可以在个人内部做到这一点，那就是你在对抗自己。
You made one judgment, and then you ask people to think, how could that judgment be wrong and then make another? And that turns out to be indeed better than merely asking the same question wise. In some ways, this provides a solution to the conundrum I posed to Danny. If noise is detectable only by studying statistical averages, how do I reduce noise in decisions I am making as an individual?
你做了一个判断，然后你要求人们思考，这个判断怎么会是错的，然后再做一个判断？事实证明，这确实比仅仅问同一个问题两次要好。在某种程度上，这为我向丹尼提出的难题提供了一个解决方案。如果噪音只能通过研究统计平均值来检测，我该如何减少我作为个人所做决策中的噪音？
The answer? Try to make the same decision over and over under different conditions. One way to tell if noises behind my decision to propose marriage is to ask myself whether I would make the same decision under different circumstances, not just on a moonlit night in the springtime, but in the a moonlit night in the springtime, but in the heat of summer or in the dead of winter. If I reach the same answer in these different settings, it's possible I could still be making a mistake, but at least I can be somewhat reassured that my decision is not the result
答案是：尝试在不同的条件下一次又一次地做出相同的决定。判断我提议结婚的决定背后是否有噪音的一个方法是，问问自己我是否会在不同的环境下做出同样的决定，不仅是在春天的月夜，而且是在春天的月夜，而在夏天的酷暑或冬天的严寒中。如果我在这些不同的环境中得出相同的答案，我可能仍然在犯错，但至少我可以稍稍安心，我的决定不是结果
of random extraneous factors. Scientists are exploring lots of ways to reduce noise. The researchers send them a lion-athen and his colleagues, devise an algorithm to advise judges on whether to grant bail to suspects. These are people who have been arrested, but who have not yet been put on trial. Keeping them in jail can cause all kinds of hardship.
随机的外部因素。科学家们正在探索很多减少噪音的方法。研究人员将他们（指代原文中的lion-athen）及其同事派遣出去，设计了一个算法来建议法官是否应准许嫌疑人保释。这些人已经被捕，但尚未接受审判。把他们关在监狱里会导致各种各样的困难。
People can lose jobs or lose custody of their children while they're incarcerated awaiting trial. It's costly for taxpayers to keep people in jail. But letting someone dangerous out of jail can cause harm. Maybe they go on to commit other crimes. The researchers had the algorithm offer advice to judges about whether to grant bail. They found that if judges incorporated the recommendations, this could reduce the number of people in jail by 42 percent without increasing the risk of crime.
人们在等待审判而被关押期间可能会失业或失去孩子的抚养权。纳税人把人关在监狱里代价高昂。但是把危险的人放出会造成伤害。也许他们会继续犯罪。研究人员让算法为法官提供关于是否准许保释的建议。他们发现，如果法官采纳这些建议，这可以在不增加犯罪风险的情况下，将监狱里的人数减少42%。
The research goes further than that, and that allowing the algorithm to inform the judge is actually not the best way of doing it. The research suggests quite strongly that when you have a judge and an algorithm that are looking at the same data, with some exceptions it's better to have the algorithm have the last word, and this is very non-intuitive. Besides being actually superior in some ways in terms of judgment, one of the things that algorithms do better than people is that they're not noisy. They're actually much more consistent.
研究还不止于此，允许算法为法官提供信息实际上并不是最好的做法。研究强有力地表明，当你有一个法官和一个算法在查看相同的数据时，除了一些例外，最好让算法拥有最后决定权，这非常反直觉。除了在判断方面在某些方面实际上更胜一筹之外，算法做得比人类更好的事情之一是它们没有噪音。它们实际上要一致得多。
Can you talk about this that in some ways one of the advantages that algorithms have is even when their judgments might not be as good as humans because they have less noise than humans, you're able to get better outcomes. Well, noise is a source of inaccuracy. And algorithms, by their nature, are noise-free. That is, when you present the same problem to two computers running the same software, they are going to give you the same answer, which is not true of different bail judges.
你能谈谈这一点吗，在某种程度上，算法的优势之一是，即使它们的判断可能不如人类好，因为它们的噪音比人类少，你也能获得更好的结果。嗯，噪音是不准确的源头。而算法天生就是无噪音的。也就是说，当你把相同的问题提交给运行相同软件的两台计算机时，它们会给你相同的答案，这对于不同的保释法官来说是不真实的。
So that advantage is, in many cases, sufficient to make algorithms superior to people. But I don't want to create the impression that our solution to the problem of noise is algorithms, because even if it were the solution, there's just too much opposition to algorithms. So ultimately, we're talking about improving judgments. In some domains, algorithms can be used, and I think where they can be used, they should be used. But this is a long process, a slow process, because human judgment is going to make the important decisions for quite a while. Isn't it interesting, though, Danny,
因此，在许多情况下，这种优势足以使算法优于人类。但我不想给人留下这样的印象，即我们解决噪音问题的方案就是算法，因为即使它是解决方案，对算法的反对也实在是太多了。所以归根结底，我们在谈论的是改善判断。在某些领域，算法可以使用，我认为在可以使用的领域，它们应该被使用。但这一个漫长的过程，一个缓慢的过程，因为人类的判断将在相当长的一段时间内做出重要的决定。丹尼，难道不有趣吗，
that when you look at the news and you see the news coverage of algorithms, I feel like just in the last year, I've seen dozens of articles talking about algorithmic bias, about how algorithms in some ways can make judgments worse. And it is the case that you can have poorly designed algorithms. You can argue that the old sentencing rules that we had, three strikes on your out, in some ways, that is an algorithm.
当你看着新闻，看到对算法的新闻报道时，我觉得就在过去的一年里，我看到过几十篇文章谈论算法偏见，谈论算法在某些情况下如何使判断变得更糟。事实确实是，你可能会拥有设计糟糕的算法。你可以争辩说，我们过去的旧量刑规则，“三振出局”，在某些方面，那就是一个算法。
But you could argue the algorithm in some ways was too crude to capture what actually needed to be done. But isn't it striking that there's so little attention that's paid by contrast to the potential good that algorithms can do because we're again we're so focused with the story of intent of saying a bad outcome happened and algorithm caused it clearly algorithms need to be thrown out the window. I mean we do not want to accept the errors that blind rules will make.
但你可以辩称，该算法在某些方面过于粗糙，无法捕捉到实际需要做的事情。但难道不引人注目的是，相比之下，人们对算法可以带来的潜在好处关注得如此之少，因为我们再次过于关注意图的故事，说发生了不好的结果并且算法导致了它，显然算法需要被扔出窗外。我的意思是，我们绝对不想接受盲目规则所制造的错误。
You know I was talking to someone who designed self-driving cars. And they realize that self-driving cars, it's not enough for them to be a hundred times safer than regular drivers. They effectively have to be almost perfect before they will be admitted. And it's that kind of bias that is completely human and natural. We like the natural over the unnatural.
你知道，我曾与一位设计自动驾驶汽车的人交谈过。他们意识到自动驾驶汽车，仅仅比普通司机安全一百倍是不够的。在它们被允许上路之前，它们实际上必须几乎完美。正是这种偏见完全是人类和自然的。我们喜欢自然的事物而不是不自然的事物。
We prefer human drivers and human doctors to make mistakes rather than self-driving cars and medical algorithms. And that's just the fact of psychology. You're talking the book about something that you call decision hygiene. And others have talked about this idea as well. What is decision hygiene and why the analogy to public health? When you're thinking of dealing with biases like a specific disease, so you can think of a vaccine or you can think of medication, which is specific a specific disease. So you can think of a vaccine or you can think of medication,
我们更喜欢人类司机和人类医生犯错，而不是自动驾驶汽车和医疗算法。这只是心理学的一个事实。你在书中谈到了一个你称之为决策卫生（decision hygiene）的概念。其他人也讨论过这个想法。什么是决策卫生，为什么会有公共卫生这个类比？当你考虑像对待特定疾病那样处理偏好时，你可以考虑疫苗，或者你可以考虑药物，它们是针对特定疾病的。所以你可以考虑疫苗，或者你可以考虑药物，
which is specific to that disease. But when you're washing your hands, you're doing something entirely different. You have no idea what germs you might be killing. And if you're good at it, you will never know because the germs are dead. And a similar distinction can be drawn between different ways of fighting errors. There is a difference between procedures that are specifically aimed at particular biases
这是针对那种特定疾病的。但是当你洗手时，你做的是完全不同的事情。你根本不知道你可能在杀死什么细菌。如果你洗得好，你永远也不会知道，因为细菌已经死去了。在对抗错误的不同方式之间，可以画出类似的区别。专门针对特定偏见的程序
and procedures that are intended generally to improve the quality of the judgment and decisions. And the way that this feeds back on the individual is that if there are procedures that are good for organizations and for repeated decisions, they should be good for individuals and for singular decisions. So if I'm a CEO of a corporation or if I'm a policy maker and I'm hearing this conversation about noise, can you give me two or three really specific suggestions on ways that I can reduce noise in my decision-making or in my company's decision-making or in my organization or community? Well, I think the first step would be to
与旨在普遍提高判断和决策质量的程序之间存在区别。这反馈到个人身上的方式是，如果有些程序对组织和重复决策有益，那么它们对个人和单一决策也应该有益。所以如果我是一家公司的首席执行官，或者如果我是一个政策制定者，我正在听取关于噪音的这段对话，你能给我两三个非常具体的建议，告诉我如何在我的决策中，或者在我公司的决策中，或者在我的组织或社区中减少噪音吗？嗯，我认为第一步将是
ask whether you have a task in the organization that is carried out by interchangeable functionaries like underwriters or emergency room physicians. They're carrying out the same task, making the same kinds of judgments, and you would like those judgments to be noise-free, to be uniform. So first of all, identify whether you have that case in your organization. If you do, we strongly recommend you measure noise. That is, you actually take those individuals, present them with similar cases, and see the, observe the variability in the judgments. And possibly that may lead you to want to do something about it. But the first step is just to measure noise because our intuition about the magnitude of
询问您的组织中是否有由可互换的职员（如承保人或急诊室医生）执行的任务。他们执行相同的任务，做出相同的判断，而您希望这些判断是没有噪音的、统一的。所以首先，确定您的组织中是否存在这种情况。如果是这样，我们强烈建议您测量噪音。也就是说，你实际上把这些个人带到一起，向他们展示类似的案例，并观察判断中的变异性。这可能会促使你想做点什么。但第一步只是测量噪音，因为我们对噪音幅度的直觉
noise are systematically wrong. Danny thinks we should learn from the saga of the rise and fall of sentencing reform. Once you detect noise in an organization, it may be wiser to avoid trying to fix the problem by asking everyone to follow rigid rules. As we've seen, people hate to have their judgement question, they hate to have their discretion limited, and they detest anything that smacks of mechanistic rules. The main thing to do, if you're attempting to improve the judgment of people in an organization is to convince those people that they want their judgments to be better. If you impose it as a set of rules that all of them will follow, they will resist it, they will feel they are being robotized
是系统性错误的。丹尼认为我们应该从量刑改革的兴衰历程中吸取教训。一旦你在一个组织中发现噪音，最好不要试图通过要求每个人遵循严格的规则来解决这个问题。正如我们所见，人们讨厌他们的判断受到质疑，他们讨厌他们的自由裁量权受到限制，他们痛恨任何带有机械化规则色彩的东西。如果你试图改善一个组织中人们的判断，最重要的事情是说服这些人，让他们自己想要让判断变得更好。如果你把它强加为一套所有人都要遵循的规则，他们会抵制，他们会觉得自己被机器化了
and they're likely to sabotage whatever you propose. I mean, this is well known in insurance companies that provide the underwriters, in many cases, with information or even with a technical price, with the suggestion about what premium should be assigned and underwriters are very likely to completely ignore those and to follow their judgment. And basically, I would think, you know, it's obvious advice. If you have a group of people who are noisy, have that group try to find the solution to the noise,
并且他们很可能会破坏你提出的任何建议。我的意思是，这在为承保人提供信息的保险公司中是众所周知的，在许多情况下，甚至提供技术价格，并对应该分配什么保费提出建议，而承保人很有可能会完全忽略这些并遵循他们自己的判断。基本上，我想，这是显而易见的建议。如果你有一群充满噪音的人，让这群人试着找到解决噪音的办法，
have them develop procedures that will make them uniform, do not impose procedures on them, but work with them to make them more uniform, because actually they will recognize that they would like to be in agreement with each other. But letting them feel that what they are doing is what they want to do, rather than what they are being forced to do. That is clearly a very important step if people really want to have organizations that improve their judgments. Daniel Kahneman, Olivia Siboni and Cass Sunstein are the authors of Nois, a flaw in human judgment.
让他们制定能使他们统一的程序，不要将程序强加给他们，而是与他们合作使他们更加统一，因为实际上他们会认识到他们希望彼此达成一致。但是让他们觉得他们正在做的事情是他们想做的事情，而不是被迫去做的事情。如果人们真的希望拥有能够改善其判断的组织，这显然是非常重要的一步。丹尼尔·卡尼曼（Daniel Kahneman）、奥利维亚·西博尼（Olivier Siboni）和卡斯·桑斯坦（Cass Sunstein）是《噪音：人类判断的缺陷》一书的作者。
Danny, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was really my pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Rosalind Tardisilius. She's a producer in New York City
丹尼，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。这真的是我的荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们今天的无名英雄是罗莎琳·塔迪西利乌斯（Rosalind Tardisilius）。她是纽约市的一名制作人
who helped us record this interview with Danny Connomen. Rosalind got to Danny's place early to set up for the interview and she was incredibly kind, conscientious and patient. At various points in my conversation with Danny, sirens blared outside. At one point, a refrigerator in Danny's apartment woke up and started making noise. Through all of it, Roslyn figured out how to get a crystal clear recording. Thank you Roslyn, you are a true on Sanghira. If you like this episode and like our show, please consider supporting us.
她帮助我们录制了这次对丹尼·康诺曼的采访。罗莎琳早早来到丹尼的住处为采访做准备，她非常善良、认真且有耐心。在我与丹尼交谈的各个时刻，警笛在外面呼啸。有一刻，丹尼公寓里的冰箱醒了过来，开始制造噪音。经历了这一切，罗莎琳想出了如何获得水晶般清晰的录音的方法。谢谢你，罗莎琳，你是一个真正的无名英雄。如果你喜欢这一集并喜欢我们的节目，请考虑支持我们。
Go to support.hiddenbrain.org to learn how you can help. Every little bit makes a difference, and it means a lot to us to see you step forward to help. I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 了解如何提供帮助。每一小点帮助都能带来改变，看到你们挺身而出给予帮助对我们意义重大。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），下周见。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。